welcome to bytes by AI where AI teaches
you gradio lets you turn your Python
scripts into web apps with just a few
lines of code here's an example that
takes a string does something and
returns it interactively while this is a
basic example the function that does
something with the string can be as
advanced as you want for example we can
pass this text to gpt2 to let it
continue generating text for us and we
do this with a mere 7 actual lines of
code that is insane radio isn't limited
to just text for example imagine copilot
wrote a classification model for you and
you want to show off your deep learning
skills to your friends you can use
gridio in a sketch input to allow your
friends to draw a number and the model
will predict what it is gradio can
handle all kinds of inputs and outputs
like text image video file uploads data
frames and more also UI inputs like
sliders radio buttons and a bunch of
others this has been a bytes by AI I
hope you enjoy and I will see you next
time